[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
ladies and gentlemen Dave Chappelle
committee Dave Chappelle hosted Saturday
Night Live this weekend which could only
mean one shocking mind-blowing thing
comedian Dave Chappelle talking about
Kanye or yay's anti-semitic comments and
about NBA star Kyrie Irving's action I
denounced anti-Semitism in all its forms
today she texted me hi I imagine you're
slammed but would still love to
interview you thank you and amazing job
on SNF this [ __ ] thinks she's texting
with Dave Chappelle she thinks he's
being ignored by Dave Chappelle she's
being ignored by you and she said to me
she's like I'm friends with your brother
that was from earlier today
three-way call her and soda right now
and do the interview yes
right
oh hey Dave how are you
doing today's Monday November 21st and
the legionist skanks Along with Dan
Soder may have just recorded the
funniest podcast moment of all time let
me explain before we watch these clips
the backstory of this whole thing is
actually very important so just really
quickly basically Fox News and tuckle
Carlson are currently in the process of
making a documentary about freedom of
speech and the current state of Comedy
so the reaching out to comedians like
big Jay oakerson Shane Gillis and Louis
J Gomez for interviews on this topic
well Fox news reporter reached out to
comedian Dave Smith about an interview
and said that she got his number from
Luis Gomez but all the texts that she's
been sending him have been completely
over the top commenting on his legendary
status just really sucking him off in
these texts now this is where it started
to get a little weird your position in
the comedy world is so giant and your
talent undeniable and despite any
backlash
you continue to hit back to hit back
harder each time and deliver even
funnier and edgier material which
directly combats any threat to
censorship you are truly proof of this
premise
at this point in the message where are
you at mentally it is no I was I'm two
sentences away from being like what like
you can compliment me to the point you
go you are brilliant and talented and I
go I get where she's coming from and
then she goes you said it really the
leader in this industry and I'm like
when you called when you called yourself
the goat I agreed it's just like a
little too much and then uh she goes
um today she texted me hi just wanted to
follow up on the above I imagine you're
slammed but would still love to
interview you thank you and amazing job
on SNL yeah
so
then it it became clear to me that this
[ __ ] thinks she's texting with Dave
Chappelle
how she could possibly have made the
connection to Lewis and gas digital and
then thought she was talking through him
starts with Lewis gave me your number
Dave Chappelle
I'm like how would you even maybe she
thought he was Louis CK
[Laughter]
so Lewis is texting this reporter
thinking that they're both talking about
Dave Smith meanwhile the reporter is
sexing Dave Smith thinking that she's
talking to Dave Chappelle the funniest
thing is no one even realizes that
there's a mix-up until everyone goes
back through Lewis's messages live on
the show she goes awesome thank you and
definitely came with a skank Fest next
year maybe we could do something further
blah blah blah so then she sent me a
link to SNL staff writer's boycott over
Chappelle's hosting gig
I didn't even see that link she sent me
never registered that that link came
so then I get a text message from her
that says hi
any chance you can get me in touch with
Dave
it's sweet though you're the first day
we thought of when he said that Dave
Chappelle Dave Smith you had mentioned
me to her so he was thinking she was
talking about that I did mention Dave
this is perfect for what our message is
about how comedy clubs and mainly
podcasts are sanctuaries for comedy that
are just Dave's number and then I said
I already know what this is but it's so
great
oh [ __ ]
how do you miss this the first time
because I see you heart reacting every
message she's sending you
I said I sent his number and I go I
mentioned it to him
if you make it easy on him I.E going to
him in Jersey I'm sure he'd do it
Dave you have to call her right now
she goes oh that's amazing thank you so
much that is amazing
that was the greatest track down ever in
her life
do you have Axel Rose's phone number
here say listen Jay she is can I mention
your name or should I call and I go
foreign
[Laughter]
comedy club in New York soon in the near
future and she goes hey I messaged you
like Louis J Gomez gave you your number
again who
the reporter thinking that Dave
Chappelle's best friend and closest
thing to a brother is Louis J Gomez
that's hilarious in its own right but
it's still not even the funniest part of
this whole situation because then they
all realize they're best friends with
Dan Soder who does a perfect Dave
Chappelle impression and this lady is
still waiting on a response so they get
Dan on the horn and merge a three-way
call to conduct a fake interview between
Fox News and Dave Chappelle he knows the
task right now he's pretending to be
Chappelle talking to Fox News about
being a state of Comedy yes
fighting PC culture if the closest thing
you have to a brother Louis J Gomez
happens to come up feel free to roll
with that
just throwing it back to Lewis over and
over so funny all right all right all
right I'm muting and now adding call
wait would you be cool you can talk but
be quiet you can't link till she answers
dude shut up this is so far everyone be
quiet it's not me shut up Dave no it's
so loud
oh hey Dave how are you
hello
hello
Hi how are you doing looking good I'm on
a train so apologies can you hear me oh
it's quite all right I just want to call
you real quick because I know I only
have about four minutes that's okay I
could have like one percent batteries
oh what is that I wanted to get in quick
and talk to you about Louis J Gomez
easily one of the funniest people I've
ever met in my life yes
I mean that man is very important to me
he is like a brother
yes I've been with him
we have established a connection that is
a bond that is unbreakable yes
you know he was incredible I mean I met
him at gas digital and he was so
influential yes visual is crazy how hard
I've seen work on it and how incredible
the one problem is the website
yeah I know I've been on this side
because I was obviously doing a research
prior to it I mean it was good I mean
he's just like incredible I didn't even
know much about him until I started
working on this and I was I'm going to
tell you right now I've seen a lot of
this stuff in comedy and Lewis is easily
a lot of people call him a Puerto Rican
rattlesnake and I have to say he is a
Puerto Rican giant he's a giant man I've
seen him I've seen him dead hundreds of
women I've seen him strong comedy
festivals they're so legendary that
people got diseases this man has done
more for comedy than anybody in the
world and his son his son James if he
doesn't eat loose will rip someone's
head off well I love that I mean
he's just crying too which is another
thing
because he's a true Peach
yeah he was very generous I mean he led
us into his entire Studio he has to
pretend this is all normal
it was just incredibly incredibly
generous what's incredible is that he
actually campaigned for Joe Biden we can
find very a lot of people don't know
that a lot of people don't know yeah
Lewis is very liberal
yeah he um we had this idea for
um you know it's a documentary episode
it's like a 30-minute episode on
exploring comedy right now because
obviously with both culture and cancel
culture there's so many questions
he acts like he isn't please he loves
wolf culture
the interesting thing when I interviewed
him is insight into what was happening
like changed our entire premise of the
documentary it was about the sanctuaries
are existing for Comics that still do
like real unfiltered because he's always
been you know the dangerous edgy comedy
if you don't know what's going to happen
exactly you don't know what but you know
what you're going to get with Louis J
Gomez
fluctuates Dangerously in weight
figured it out yet
I'm uh filming a documentary series of
fox about how there's never been a
better time for comedy despite uh hyper
politicized she thinks you have
Chappelle's number three-way call her
and soda right now and do the interview
[Applause]
just based on this moment alone Dan
Soder you're a comedy Hall of Famer this
was insane the impression was perfect
the fact that he was just chilling
playing video games got a random phone
call and was able to do this on the Fly
tremendous the full video is hilarious
it's about 30 minutes long posted on the
legionist gangs YouTube channel I would
definitely recommend watching it in
length after this video but what a thing
what a thing that happened your mom's
house is teaming up with Bobby Lee this
holiday season to bring us all a
Christmas themed live show starting
December 9th personally I think it's a
great idea for your mom's house to start
having guests on the live shows Tim
Dylan was on the one they did before
this and he brought a lot of excitement
to the show and I feel like this is a
perfect situation for Bobby Lee to be in
a live show there's less restrictions on
what you can say or more importantly
what you can do so I feel like this is a
situation where Bobby's Really Gonna
Thrive yeah I took Bobby Lee
uh to Canada two weeks ago it was
[ __ ] unbelievably fun yeah my crew
had never met anybody like that in their
life though they were all like this guy
said it was [ __ ] mind yeah like he's
like your boy's crazy he's crazy and
it's real I think yeah it's genuine the
show begins December 9th at 9pm and
tickets are on sale right now for just
ten dollars or for fifty dollars you
could get the VIP ticket which includes
a Josh Potter pre-show and some ymh
merch guest spots from last week your
mom's house talked with Stavros Bert was
not on two bears one cave it was Tom and
Quentin Tarantino flagrant had on Dr
huberman whiskey Ginger talked with Neil
Brennan kill Tony tonight is Ryan long
and Chris faga and Ari shaffir was on
tigerbelly Jersey that's posing too
again this you think this is yeah you
[ __ ]
you know I hate the lake whose jersey is
that
I've never seen Bobby wear a basketball
jersey yeah I love jerseys man I love
this team and I love this guy
how's it doing this year this past
weekend and Theo Von also talked with
Ari shaffir Joe Rogan Experience this
week with Stevo we might be drunk talked
with Mateo Lane are you garbage and the
boys talked with Natasha Leggero Tom
seguro was on Stevo's wild ride and
garyvee was the guest on the Tim Dillon
show as far as new stand-up specials go
there's a few out right now that are
worth checking out we'll start off with
Neil Brennan blocks you can find that on
Netflix and according to their
description from the weird relationship
humans have with dogs to how dating a
model is like owning a dune buggy Neil
Brenham uses on his life in this
stand-up special you also have Kurt
brand Hall perfectly stupid and Ari
shaffir Jew those are both out right now
but Bert Kreischer has also announced
that he just finished taping his Netflix
special so they'll be out soon I mean
there's not a lot of specials coming out
nowadays or if there's more I might have
missed him comment some some specials I
might have missed it is hard to keep up
with all these but that's why you're
here at the joke World crime the update
where the whole comedy world is summed
up for you all in one place please
subscribe that does it for this week's
stroke World comedy update as always
thank you so much for watching this
video supporting the channel we'll be
back again next Monday with some more
comedy news but in the meantime we're
going to be posting some other great
content on this channel related to
Comedy and related to your favorite
comedians so you might as well subscribe
you know go ahead subscribe if you're
watching this far you definitely should
subscribe follow us on Instagram we have
Instagram that we're trying to grow
trying our very best to grow it's at 10
000 followers which I'm very proud of
but this thing's at 150 000 followers so
maybe we get these people to also go
over to Instagram
a problem solved
have a great Thanksgiving if I don't see
you before then
eat some turkey if you don't celebrate
Thanksgiving I'm really sorry for being
so insensitive
um
peace
[Music]